if venom's success the first time around
was largely due to the elements of
surprise and strangeness what could the
second one have up its sleeve
a lot potentially while the law of
diminishing returns runs rampant in
hollywood sequels venom ii could
actually improve upon its predecessor
making venom the center of his own
franchise presents sony with some unique
challenges and possibilities
after all it's not very often that a
comic book character who's usually a
villain or an anti-hero
becomes the protagonist of a comic book
franchise luckily
for sony venom has a nemesis of his own
carnage
carnage entered the marvel universe in
the early 90s when writer david mikelini
came up with the idea of a symbiote
stripped of venom's moral code
along with artist eric larson he
introduced cletus cassidy
a deranged serial killer and eddie
brock's prison cellmate
after coming into contact with some of
venom's drippings cassidy became carnage
a blood-red monster that's fought both
venom and spider-man over the years
needless to say carnage creeping to the
big screen in venom 2 will make for a
wild ride
carnage's appearance in the venom sequel
was promised by the movie's mid-credits
sequence
if you got up and left the theater as
soon as that eminem song kicked in you
missed a performance with the potential
to match tom hardy's and fearless
weirdness
eddie brock is sent to prison to
interview notorious serial killer cletus
cassidy played by woody harrelson
when i get out of here and i will
there's gonna be carnage the venom
blu-ray offered an extended version of
the scene giving harrelson a little
extra time to make an impression
talk about sucking out their eyeballs
crunchy on the outside with harrelson's
history of going all out as
mesmerizingly unstable characters in
movies like natural-born killers and
seven psychopaths
harrelson's expanded role in venom 2
promises to push it even more over the
top than its predecessor
sony's plans to explore the dark corners
of spider-man's world go beyond venom
and carnage
in 2018 the studio made the somewhat
left-field announcement that jared leto
would be starring in morbius
for those unfamiliar morpheus the living
vampire has been a spider-man supporting
character since the 70s
although he really came into his own
during the same 90s goth craze that
propelled venom to stardom
very little is known about the plot of
the morbius movie
but sony is pretty much guaranteed to
link these two anti-heroes in their
effort to keep up with the cinematic
universe game
the possible introduction of vampires
into sony's spider-verse
opens up some intriguing new
supernatural doorways for venom 2.
even if eddie brock can't hold a candle
to our favorite vampire hunter
you give frost a message for me you tell
him it's open season on all
success
we know that a venom sequel is coming
and that tom hardy and woody harrelson
are contracted to star
but that's really all we know for
certain jeff pinkner co-writer of the
first movie couldn't confirm any more
than that
in a recent interview with the
discussing film youtube channel can't
say anything other than that it is
happening
okay it's happening are you writing it
or is that
i i i am not but while that was all the
writer could say with certainty he did
drop one other major statement
it is not impossible that in a
future slash upcoming venom movie uh
spider-man will play a significant role
with sony's rapidly expanding
spider-verse a potential cameo by the
web head could take many forms maybe tom
holland's mcu peter parker would swing
by
or perhaps another alternate universe
incarnation would be the foil to hardy's
eddie brock
regardless a crossover would be sure to
get fan's senses tingling
superhero origins can be complicated
that's why comics history is so full of
reboots retcons and reimaginings
it's also why the plot of the venom
movie was sometimes messy
take a look at most reviews and you'll
find that the story structure is one of
the most commonly criticized elements
sometimes superhero sequels are stronger
than their predecessors
captain america the winter soldier
outshone the first avenger
thor ragnarok proved that the third time
could be the charm
and the dark knight unquestionably
topped batman begins done right venom 2
has the perfect opportunity to address
the first movie's biggest issues
even the negative reviews of venom
tended to dish out some positive
comments about tom hardy's bizarre duel
performance as eddie brock and venom
it's no surprise that venom appealed to
a performer as adventurous as tom hardy
after all the job required him to tackle
the primal acting challenge of
performing two-person dialogues with
himself
in fact he may have had a little too
much fun to fit in the movie as he
revealed during the press junket that
much of his favorite material didn't
make the final cut there are
like 30 40 minutes worth of scenes that
aren't in this movie
your favorite ones all of them although
trimming down a film's more indulgent
passages is a normal part of the
filmmaking process
it's hard not to wonder how entertaining
all those scenes of hardy enjoying
himself would be
now that it's clear what a strong asset
his eccentric choices were in the first
movie
maybe the sequel will give him even more
room to play
[Music]
in his review for that shelf critic
victor schiff said
venom feels like several competing films
a jekyll and hyde story an odd couple
movie a broad comedy
stitched together into one incoherent
mess it's hard to completely disagree
gritty violence emotional melodrama and
wacky sci-fi goofs are all held together
within the movie's gooey structure
even when the individual elements make
for a fun ride it sometimes feels like a
movie that isn't quite sure what kind of
total pitcher it's going for
of course some of that tonal dissonance
could be considered an accurate
reflection of eddie brock's splitting
psyche as he adjusts to the idea of
playing host to an alien entity
and let's not forget that it's basically
a spider-man movie without spider-man
a pitch so odd that some uncertainty on
the part of the filmmakers is
understandable
now though the creators of the sequel
can look back at the finished product to
build a stronger foundation to support
the next chapter
parasites yeah it's the term of
endearment that's all
apologize no apologize
all right fine i'm sorry even during
those early days of venom hype when no
one knew quite what to expect
fans always had a checklist of things
their favorite symbiotes big adventure
should contain
a movie about venom should be dark it
could definitely get violent it
absolutely must get weird and it could
potentially even get a little kinky
there was a certain amount of
disappointment then when the mpaa
slapped the finished product with a
crowd-friendly pg-13
now the venom has proven successful
enough to get a sequel sony might also
consider it worth investing in a more
niche film
even if venom 2 is another pg-13 outing
more intense footage could be saved for
an alternate home video cut
like it or not fans romantically
shipping eddie brock and venom was
inevitable it's no surprise that a movie
as bizarre and meme worthy as venom
would inspire fans to spend way too much
time thinking about the bond between its
two intertwined main characters
whether you see it as an interstellar
buddy movie strangely star-crossed
rom-com
or a very particular kind of fetish
story it's undeniable that much of
venom's charm is in the interplay
between a boy and his blob
i'm putting my hands up you are making
us look bad
i know why i'm not
yes you are of course it took a long
time for these two to become one
much of the movie was dedicated to
introducing eddie setting up the
symbiote's arrival on earth
contriving their accidental encounter
and running them through the trials of
their partnership
it wasn't until the story neared its
climax that they really started working
together
finally blossoming into the weird little
family they were meant to be
the sequel can take their relationship
to new levels maybe even some weird
levels
[Music]
do you feel me what the hell are you
[Music]
we are there
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
marvel movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one